where are some couples happy and some
are straight-up
miserable I was connecting with your mom
where are you stop acting like a child
were you on your period
[Music]
one way to understand how relationships
work is a concept of attachment theory
attachment theory is the idea that the
way that your parents treated you as a
baby affects even romantic relationships
as an adult mmm Apple II there are three
types of adult attachment secure anxious
and avoidant a securely attached person
has healthy relationships they are
confident that their needs will be met
by their partner and they can depend on
them alright I attempted to make a latte
ah thank you
I saved you the calendar section where's
my latte who are you did you get in my
house an anxious person has a fear of
rejection and abandonment so they're
always worried that their partner will
leave them where are you going
are you mad at me I'm going to the
bathroom oh okay
I love you uh don't you want to say
something I love you too thank you
text me a person with an avoidant
attachment style feels uncomfortable
with intimacy when they get close to
another person they tend to panic and
pull away hey I want to tell you
something hmm
I love you it's late I have to go wash
my friend's bird what are you talking
about lay a gala [ __ ] around I just
said I love you
[Music]
no no don't even please stop according
to a study done in the 1980s 56% of
people are secure 19% are anxious and
25% are avoidant what can you do if
you're an anxious or an avoidant one way
you can prove your relationships is by
learning more talk to a therapist read
books and articles about attachment
theory educate yourself also to insecure
attachments do not work well with one
another
hi I'm a classic avoiding high textbook
anxious nice to meet you sweetie - by
the way as soon as we fall in love
I will panic and immediately run away oh
that's perfect because as soon as you
start to run away I'm gonna get super
clingy like do you have a Facebook and
Instagram others stalk you sound like a
disaster I am I'm gonna disappear it'll
be like I never existed oh it's gonna
devastate so turned on right now sing if
you're anxious aren't avoidant try being
a relationship with a secure person
being with a secure person can calm your
neuroses and put you at ease
I'm gonna use a bathroom I'll be right
back oh you don't have to tell me where
you're going
look I am completely secure now okay so
you can go to the bathroom you can flirt
with other women I mean you could text
your eggs I mean we want to have an open
relationship with the talk I don't that
I don't want to do any of that oh good
thing I don't want to do anything
whatever your attachment style is you
are worthy of love and can still have
successful relationships so just be
aware of your patterns and make positive
choices also I have a drink in margarita
since 10:00 a.m. so I'm feeling pretty
positive
[Music]
it's gonna be a good summer I can feel
it
[Music]